rolls-royce first of all one of
Britain's most famous corporate names
has reported its worst ever lost one of
the biggest in UK corporate history the
jet engine maker posted a pre-tax loss
of 4.6 billion pounds for 2016 that
included the record bribery charges
announced last month paid to US UK and
Brazilian authorities amounting to 671
million pounds but the vast bulk of the
losses came from a 4.4 billion pound
right down on derivatives designed to
protect them from currency moves that
was largely down to the fall in sterling
now we were hoping to talk to
rolls-royce chief executive Rory nice at
some points but he told us then that he
didn't have enough time happily i'm
joined though by howard Wilden an
independent defense and aerospace
analyst now how list it get to that
point first I thought that the falling
pound was supposed to help out
manufacturers and Exporters why isn't it
worked for rolls-royce it works two ways
okay over the in the preceding years
when the pound has been has been strong
because of their hedging policy they've
actually gained so suddenly of course in
2016 when we had this dramatic drop in
sterling the like of which we haven't
seen in a long time that had a major
major impact which they couldn't they
couldn't avoid covering because it's
very very difficult to know to know
where we're going to be one two and
three years now we're in a very very
different world so they have come
because of transparency they want to be
more open they've decided to make sure
that they are completely up-to-date
shall we say in terms of their in terms
of their clergy remember they have to
hedge because because they make here
they sell the world everything's priced
in dollars but they're making in Euro or
sterling where is or indeed in signal
flares one of the perils of the job
let's let's have a look shall we at the
share price of rolls-royce one of the
biggest fallers as well come on to today
down four percent there we can see 29
and a half p you know this this was a
disappointment even looking beyond
looking beyond those those costs that
comes it comes at a bad time for the
company we've had the unfortunate into
incident relation of the SFO that's
clear that's now behind them
as a company that the SFO incidents I
mean let's let's just remind ourselves
shall we I mean you know David Cameron
I've got it got a little quote that we
should read here you know we're talking
about one of the big companies for the
UK UK here and David Cameron when he was
talking about rolls-royce he said that
they were a world leader in the
development of advanced technologies of
which the country can be proud I mean
you know it does look rather awkward
they are a world lead he was absolutely
right they are a world leader and
there's something that we should be very
proud of here in the UK they have been
for many many years and they will be
again in the future they have a massive
order book to go to go to go forward
with yes they've admitted they put the
hands up that the system that should
have been fully in operation since
regulations changed the bribery reactant
and the various other regulations that
not just the UK but other countries have
signed up to you know it collectively
and individually that he didn't work and
but they've admitted it and I think that
we can put that behind us final point
question is is it all over as this now
kind of in the past because there but
there is still technically speaking of
threat of prosecution hanging them over
if they don't behave is that right well
yeah of course the reason so there
should be that really about things about
this job is typically for the company it
is it is behind them now they've got to
get on continue to take the cost the
cost out the pregnant package which
there which will take in the three years
it's going to be a three tough years for
them I'm not I'm not saying that we
won't be back here next year discussing
some supra notes some issues because it
takes time to rebuild but they are on
the way they achieve more in this last
year than they set out to do